[音楽]
[拍手]
私の一番の仕事は母であることだと思って
います
私は完璧な母親ではありませんし
毎日手抜きばかりしています
もちろん大変な日もあるし
子育てについて全く悩みがないわけでは
ありませんが息子が与えてくれる無条件の
愛をいっぱい感じながら彼と過ごす毎日が
幸せで
お給料が出るわけではないけれど私にとっ
て一番やりがいや誇りがある仕事なんです
息子を出産してからすべてが変わりました
わたしがこの子はなんとしてでも守らなく
ちゃいけないという強い気持ちが生まれ
妊娠中には子どもを優先することなんて
できなかったのですが
息子が生まれた瞬間からはぁになったと
実感しました
私は息子に海という名前をつけたのでいつ
からかこの子に綺麗な女を残したいという
思いが生まれそれまであまり関心がなかっ
た環境問題にも少しずつ興味を持ち始め
ました
昔から買い物するときにレジ袋を断ったり
朝は電気を使わなかったりということは
意識していましたが
私たちが直面している環境問題について
全く分かっていませんでした
買い物に行くとそのすべてはプラスチック
に包まれていて
それらは分別することなくゴミとなり
分別してもそのほとんどはリサイクルされ
ずゴミになります
皆さんもビーチでゴミの山や海にプカプカ
浮かんでいるゴミをご覧になってことが
ある方もおられるのではないでしょうか
私には何ができるんだろう
いろいろ調べているうちに
0 s とフォーム
ごみを出さないシンプルな暮らしという
ふうに出会い衝撃を受けました
その本の著者
ベアジョンソンは玉さんと2人の子供たち
そして一匹のワンちゃんと暮らしている
家族でカリフォルニアに住んでいるんです
が1年間に出すゴミの量がなんと約1
リットルだというのです
0 s とという言葉にはゴミを出さない
無駄をなくすという意味があるのですが
その方には私が知りたかった答えがすべて
書かれていました
買い物には自身の容器を待ち運び必要な分
だけ量り売りができるお店鳥用意したり
生ゴミを堆肥としてお野菜を育てたり
欲しいものがあればそれは長く使えるのか
壊れてしまったときに環境負荷になるゴミ
になってしまわないかなどを意識したり
することでゴミの量を減らすことができ
ます
自分で3身近にできることから始めれば
いいんだと改めて気付き
ずっと染め続けていた髪を染めるのをやめ
たり
マイクロプラスチックとして流れてしまう
食器スポンジを自然由来のものに変えたり
お肉を食べることを減らしてみたり
電気代は毎月1万円だったのがエアコン
使うのを止めて今では1000円になり
ました
道端に落ちている目の前にある込みにも目
を向けるようになり
息子が1歳の頃から一緒にゴミ拾いをやり
始めました
子供の頃からゴミ拾いをしていると大人に
なっても絶対にポイ捨てをしないくなる
そうです
世界にたくさん触れているゴミ思うと些細
なことに感じてしまうこともありましたが
私たちの行動がきっかけで周りの友人達も
一緒に声を上げてくれたり
共感してくれる人たちに出会ったりする
ことで継続して続けることの大切さに
改めて気づかされています
子育てにいっぱいいっぱいになりながらも
もっと環境問題について勉強したいと毎日
少しずつ調べていくと畜産動物たちについ
ての実態も見えてきました
畜産動物と言われる動物たちが環境に多大
な負荷を与えているだけではなく
どのように飼育されているのかが分かり
それは見ているだけでつらいものでした
種差別という言葉をみなさんはご存知です
か
犬や豚は知能や感覚も似ていて
同じ生き物同士一緒に仲良く遊んだりもし
ます
こぶたも子犬も同じかわいい動物なのです
がこの命は可愛がる命
この命は肉として食べるものとそんな風に
差別をして人間が命をさばいているわけ
です
私は息子への授乳を経験したことで私が
もし牛だったらと考えるとウシたちの痛み
が痛いほど分かりました
私は授乳に慣れるまで約4カ月かかり
夜中はその痛みで泣いたりする日も多かっ
たのですが
慣れていくにつれて
それは愛情ホルモンが溢れる時間となり
子供との大切なコミュニケーションに
つながることを体感しました
牛たちも我が子を愛し
炒めを感じる動物ですが
牛乳を生産するために
人工的に妊娠させられます
お母さん足は後ろを振り向くこともできず
狭い場所に閉じ込められているので
赤ちゃんの顔を見ることもできず
生まれたばかりの講師はお母さんの
おっぱいを味わうことなく
搾乳機で人間のために搾り取られて
そしてお乳の出が悪くなると再び人工妊娠
を繰り返され最後には食用に行くとして
殺されます
動物たちのいのちについて考えるように
なったり
そんな風に育てられたお肉を食べたくない
と思うようになり私はビーガンになること
を選択しました
そしてヴィーガンは環境問題や動物犠牲を
減らすだけでなく健康や貧困問題など
sdg ずの解決にもつながっていること
を知り
シンプルなライフスタイルがわたしにとっ
て心地の良い選択だと実感するようになり
ました
ヴィーガンになって周りの人たちに理解は
してもらえるもののお肉を食べないなんて
を否定されることもあり最初は孤独に
感じることもありました
でもラッキーなことに家から動産府のお店
にほとんどのメニューが b がの
レストランを見つけたり
友人たちがミイラのスイーツなどを作って
いたりして
いつのまにか沢山のつながりができてい
ました
b がを実践するうえで安心できる材料を
使って好きなものを食べるにはもちろん
自炊が一番なのですが私は外食もよくし
ます
実は京都には約200店舗ほどビーガンの
レストランやビーガンオプションがあるお
店があります
イタリアンをはじめさまざまなレストラン
で聞いてみると快くヴィーガン対応して
くれるところもあり身近なところから
始めることができます
動物さん可哀想だねこれはビーガン7
トムスクが話すようになったり
明石の中身も何が入っているのかなど一緒
にパッケージをチェックしたり
日がについて少しずつ理解していて毎日
驚かされています
ゴミ拾いやビーガンの生活を通して今まで
クリアに見えていなかったことに気づかせ
てくれたのは薄くが生まれてきてくれた
おかげです
私自身毎日学びの連続で息子からたくさん
のことを教わっています
そんな息子にも視野を広くいろんな世界を
見てほしいという思いがあり今まで二人で
一緒に4カ国を旅してきました
その中の一つの国バヌアツ共和国という
ところにご縁があり息子が2歳の頃に4
カ月間住んでいました
透き通るブルーの美しいラブん
オーガニックの野菜やフルーツがいっぱい
のしま
ひと言で言うとパラダイスです
息子といろんな場所を訪れながらこれから
も新しい体験をしていきたいという思いで
一度日本に帰国し
次の行き先を考えていたとき昨年から
パンデミックが始まりました
今まで当たり前にできていたことができ
なくなり
扉が閉ざされたようにも感じました
でも改めて本当に大切なものは何なのか
気づくことができたり
日本でできることは何なのか向き合う
きっかけとなった年でした
まず行ってみたかった畑をレンタルして
野菜の作り方を息子と一緒に学び始めまし
た二人で話になって土を触っていると
とってもリラックスできて
虫さんやお野菜が育っていくの監査室し
たりするのを見ながら息子も野菜が好きに
なりました
無農薬の虫さんがいっぱいついているお
野菜はおいしいと分かり
夏はキュウリや唐辛子を生のままパリパリ
食べています
その頃息子あ3歳になり周りのお友達が
幼稚園を選び始めていたりあなたはどう
するのと聞かれるために私はこういった
自然の中での体験や
現在実践しているライフスタイルを変える
ことが想像できませんでした
子供と一緒に過ごせる時間は本当に限られ
ていて
できる限り一緒に過ごし
成長を見守りながら
私も一緒に体験したり学んでいきたいと
いう思いや
学ぶ場所はスクールだけでなくいろんな
選択肢があってもいいんじゃないかという
思いがますます強くなり
今現在4歳の息子は幼稚園など通わず
ホームスクールしています
ホームスクールとはその名の通りお家で
勉強するということなんですが
その家庭によって
全く違います
海外ではホームスクールをしている家族も
多く船で世界を回りながら生活している
家族や
しっかりカリキュラムを組みながら実践し
ている家族などやり方は本当に様々です
でも私がなぜホームスクールを選択したか
というと
いちばんの理由は私自身が子供の時ホーム
スクールをしていたからです
私は保育園の時からスクールという場所が
苦手で小学校中学校
ほとんど学校に通わずに家で勉強してい
ました
当時ホームスクールという言葉をもちろん
知っていたわけではないのですが
両親は困り果てて仕方なくそんな私を
受け入れ
通信教育や習い事に通わせていました
友達に恵まれなかったわけではないですが
何となく自分の居場所がここではないなあ
とずっと感じていました
今でも覚えていることは小学校1年生の時
に先生が私に意見を聞いたときのことです
私は勇気を出して自分の意見を伝えたの
ですが
それは間違っているという言葉が返ってき
ました
本当の思いを伝えたにも関わらず自分が嘘
をついたような気持ちになるんそれから
みんなの前で発言したりすることができ
なくなってしまう
自分の席でおもらしをしてしまったことも
あります
沢山のクラスメイトたちが手紙を書いて
くれたり家に遊びに来てもくれました
私が学校に行かない理由は病気だと伝え
られていたので
早く元気になって学校に来てねっずっと
励ましてくれたりしていました
ただその言葉は私にとってプレッシャーで
学校に行っていないことで後ろめたさも
あったので
日はほとんど出かけることなく引きこもっ
ていました
小学校からカウンセリングを受けていたの
ですが
今思い返すとそれは私にとってとても貴重
な時間でした
当時の私は同じ歳の子たちと話すより大人
の人たちと話そうが好きでカウンセラー
たちは私を一人の大人のように接して
くださる
自分と何度も向き合うことができたんだと
思います
母の仕事の関係で小さい頃から外国人の方
達と触れ合う機会も多く
なんとなく学校だけではなく
それ以外の世界があるんだなぁと知ってい
た気がします
私の中で高校に行く選択肢もなかったの
ですが高校は自分で選んでもいいよと父に
言われて分厚い高校案内の本の中から一つ
の高校を見つけました
その高校はインターナショナルスクールで
写真には黒人の先生が映っていました
それを見てこの学校なら差別されること
なく受け入れてもらえそうだなぁと直感的
に思いました
早く私の過去を知る人たちや両親のもとを
離れたかったので寮に入ることもなんとか
両親にも受け入れてもらい
海外から来た留学生たちと一緒に暮らし
ながら高校生活をスタートしました
高校生になると自分の意見が言えなくなる
子が多いと聞きます
でも私は高校生になって優しくて理解ある
先生や友人たちのおかげで人前でやっと
自分の意見が言えるようになりました
息子のスクール選びについて
無理やり連れていくのはどうしても抵抗が
ありました
学校が苦手だった過去もあるし何より息子
が私と一緒にいたいと言ってくれていて
きっとそんな風に言ってくれる期間は
とても短いと感じていたからです
ホームスクールをしている知人も何人か
海外にはいたものの日本では学校に行か
ないということは未だにネガティブな
イメージが強いと感じます
でも日本でホームスクールをされていた方
の本読んだり
実践されている方たちと愛するうちに
やっぱりホームスクールをしようと決心し
ずっとプレッシャーに感じていた幼稚
園選びから解放されました
息子はまだ小さいので勉強などは特にして
いませんが
これからたくさんの選択肢が増えている中
それぞれが
それぞれのスタイルで学ぶことができる
ことを伝えたい
そしてママやパパたちが悩みは思いを
シェアできるようなホームスクールの
コミュニティを作りたい
と友人と一緒に今年の9月から少しずつ
活動しています
私は息子と2人暮らしでほとんど毎日一緒
に行動しています
仕事も息子がいてもできることを選択し
たり
海外に行くことが今は難しいので
日本でまだ行ったことがない場所に行き
たいなあと私は10都道府県を一緒に回っ
たりしながら楽しくを育てをしています
息子も友達に恵まれ
いろんな場所にお友達がいて
たし上の子達には遊んでもらったり
年下の子たちにはお兄ちゃんらしく面倒を
見てあげたりしています私がそんな経験を
通してみなさんにシェアしたいことは
子供が苦しい思いをしているとき
その子の声に耳を傾け
本当に大切なことは何なのかに意識を向け
ていろんな選択肢を考えてみてほしいと
いうことです
私たちは得意なこと好きなことがみんな
違います
学校でみんなと同じ教育を受け
用意された課題をこなしていくのではなく
私は子供が興味があることを尊重し自身で
やりたいことを見つけて
学び自分の力でクリエイトする力を身に
つけて欲しいと考えています
それは子供たちだけではなく社会人の人
たちお母さんやお父さん
すべての人たちに言えます
みんなこうじゃないといけないという
決まりはないしみんな違う色があっていい
はずです
私は母であることが一番の仕事だと言い
ましたがだからといって自分がしたいこと
を諦めているわけではありません
子育ても仕事も遊びも思う存分楽しみ
ながらこれから私ができることを実践し
挑戦し続けます
でもそのすべては私1人の力だけではでき
ません
皆さん一人一人が声を上げてつながること
ができたら私はより良い世界になると信じ
ています
みんなで助け合い
循環する社会を作るために一緒に考え行動
していきませんか
子どもたちの未来のために
ああああああ
[拍手]